Det var ju som ett iPhone-moment, inget snack.
I vår bransch så var det så här, det var lågkonjunktur plus chattypity, som en gnista.
Vi tappade 75% av kunderna, så på riktigt nästan överrennade.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Rabi Salem från Contentor till podden Make Sweden Strong.
Tjena.
Hallå, hallå.
Stått tack.
Jag tänkte väl egentligen att vi ska prata om Contentor för det är ju en ganska intressant resa.
Ni är ju, jag kanske hårdrar det, men ni är en översättningsbyrå.
Och jag tänker att det måste vara typ den tuffaste omställningsresan någon bransch har gjort de senaste åren i hela AI-spåren.
Jag pratar aldrig om AI i den här podden, jag tycker att alla andra pratar om det.
Men här blir det liksom så bundet till ett business case så det tänkte jag att vi skulle prata om.
Men innan vi börjar prata om det så får vi börja lite prata om dig och vad du sysslar med.
Vem är du?
Ja men det är alltid svårt att exakt beskriva sig.
Men jag kan väl säga så, Babi Salendor bor i södra delen av Sverige, Helsingborg.
Jag hör kanske på dialekten att jag har uttryck sedan här.
Jag tänkte säga, det hör jävligt tydligt.
Jag är Helsingborg, jag har såklart varit utflugen här, jag har snart precis fyllt 45 år, så jag har några år på nacken och hunnit svänga om på lite olika ställen.
Faktiskt född i Beirut, jag är palestinier ursprungligen men kom tidigt till Sverige, jag var sex och ett halvt innan Sverige, så han vill bo på ett antal olika ställen under vår flykt, så jag har faktiskt bott på tre kontinenter.
Men berätta om mig då också generellt.
Det klassiska är ju såklart att bara hoppa rakt in, jag har gjort detta och det, men jag tror att ska man sätta någon stämpel så är jag väldigt nyfiken, jag har alltid varit väldigt intresserad av lärande, såklart utmaningar, men också att träffa både människor och företag och hava i allt som handlar om entreprenörskap, business, kunskap om samhället och människan.
Sen så har det råkande bra blivit att det har blivit ännu mer lärande på sistone, särskilt det du precis nämnde.
Där vill jag bara nämna, du nämnde att ni är en översättningsbyrå, och jag kanske, jag är ju en ordnörd då också, så jag vill skönta med att vi har slutat översätta, men jag tror att vi levererar de bästa översättningarna.
Jag kan ha fel.
Och sen så tänker jag att du nämnde att...
Det måste vi komma tillbaka till sen i alla fall.
Det får vi prata om sen.
Jag vet inte vad du sa sen, att ni...
Det var i alla fall någonting som på något sätt indikerar att vi har...
Att vi har ju tatt oss in och hur...
Är jag påvart?
Och då menar jag bara påvart.
Det ser ut som att jag lär just nu, men jag lider.
Det är ren ångest också.
Så vi är mitt i det skulle jag säga.
Så på ena sidan så är det väldigt positivt, för det går inte att missa i min värld.
Men på andra sidan så är det fy fan, vad jobbigt.
Det är inget snack.
Normalt sett brukar jag bara grotta in rakt in i det, så jag tycker det är mest intressant.
Men jag känner på något sätt att om vi hoppar in i det direkt så kommer inte jag komma ut ur det sen, för då är det där vi hamnar.
Så det är därför jag håller mig i utkanten lite grann.
Du sa att du var nyfiken, och det tycker jag går igen.
Jag pluggade ju dig lite innan vi satt oss här och snackade.
Du är ju inte med i ett bolag, du är ju med i ett gäng olika bolag.
Varför håller du på sådär?
Är du så spretig eller hinner du med i allting?
Ja, det vet jag faktiskt inte.
Men jag tror ändå att jag är mer systematisk, metodisk och strategisk än vad man kan tro.
Sen har jag alltid varit...
Jag har sagt ja kanske lite för ofta, jag skulle säga dock då det ständigt är tio år, så har jag övat någonting jag kallar snabba nej och långsamma ja.
Så det du har sett med mina engagemang, jag tror jag arbetar i en sju eller åtta stödelser, kanske två tre för många, men jag kommer jag ska förklara mitt resonemang kring det.
Och nu pratar jag faktiskt också till min fru, hon kommer inte lyssna på detta tänker jag, men hon är ständigt på mig.
Jag tror att man lär sig extremt mycket genom att träffa många olika kontexter.
Och sen så är jag...
Jag får frågor och jag är optimist i många många sammanhang, och sen så är jag lite för fåfängd, så att när någon frågar så kanske jag tänker, oj då är jag bra ju.
Är detta argumentet till din fru?
Det är lite argumentet till min fru.
Hon godkänner inte de argumenten.
Nej det gör hon inte.
Hon tycker att jag gör för mycket.
Men min huvudutsysselsättning är faktiskt min fru och mina två barn.
Allt jag gör vilar på livsmission.
Min livsmission är min familj och sen så är det att göra den här ladden lite bättre.
Nu när jag började i gråhårig och mindre år så har jag insett att göra världen bättre måste inte vara nödvändigtvis att jag ska vara med om en unicorn eller förändra hela världen.
Jag kan faktiskt betyda väldigt mycket för få människor och det är väl mognadsfrågor som jag har landat i på sistone.
Men kort bara för att man ska få lite kontext.
Jag är huvudsydelsesättningen arbetsmässigt, det är att jag är vd och delar graf på Contentor.
Här har jag varit i mer än åtta år.
Jag är också involverad i det stället där jag var vd innan.
Pro-Apps, Sveriges bästa säljbolag, sysslar med Influence Marketing, de senaste reklamprodukterna.
Jag investerar i ett antal olika, jag har knappt några pengar, men alla pengar jag har har jag lärt mig att försöka sätta igång och få arbeta.
Då har jag hoppat in med små, små postor, men då får jag sammanhang och tvingas förstå det där och lära mig.
Sedan arbetar jag i ett antal styrelser, bland dem är Econ Booster, jag är med på, kanske relevant för dig Joel, jag har jobbat här nu.
Kanske det vassaste styrelsen som jag arbetar i är Filbron Arena, med Kristoffer Blomqvistar som vd.
Det är en gammal kund till oss, vi sålde till dem för åtta, nio år sedan.
Inga stora grejer, jag var tvungen att kolla upp vad vi sålde för jag kände igen namnet.
Jag tror vi har sålt för sammanlagt 25 000, så det är inte vår största kund.
Kanske dags igen då.
Jag har gjort en grym resa och fangeringspunkten i alla dessa är återigen att jag tänker inte att jag gör sju, åtta grejer, utan jag gör ungefär en till tre grejer, men alla de har hävstång på varandra.
Så jag kommer oftast in som någon slags ofrivillig AI-expert, jag fattar inte varför.
Kantine, duktig på att driva fram mat, handlingskraftig, sälj.
Men jag tror att min absoluta styrka är den här nyfikenheten.
Kanske är Jarvar en gemenemann, jag är nog inte rädd för att vi kan gilla varandra, men jag kan ändå gå på och behandla dig.
Jag tycker att man behandlar varandra som nästan en bror eller syster.
Och då tänker jag så att man tycker om varandra och då kan man vara extremt bra.
Det är väl min take på vad jag sysslar med.
Jag gör säkert en massa annat också.
Jag har hållit på med fotboll också.
Slänga in det på slutet, det är det viktiga.
Exakt, exakt.
Gott, det är liksom den stora styrelsegrejen.
När du är med i alla de här styrelserna, kan du inte ge oss lite bara någon sorts liten tips om vad en bra styrelse är och vad en dålig styrelse är?
Jag tänker att du har sett ett gäng.
Ja, men jag kan säga så, det är ju inte ett state skulle jag säga.
Min take är att i stort sett alla styrelseorganisationer är i viss mån dysfunktionella.
Så det är ganska, det är sällan, det är bra.
För det första, styrelse är, om man tar de vanliga, det är ganska tråkigt.
Det är precis som det låter, det är för mycket möte, det är för mycket administration, det är för mycket biokrati, formellt och så vidare.
Å andra sidan så är det det starka i det här delen.
Det är på något sätt, tänk att du är på en båt och så får du hålla fast i någonting när det blåser.
Det är det som är tanken.
Riktigt bra styrelse, tycker jag.
De har, jag ska säga, mer än 50 procent, drömscenariot är mer än 80 procent är strategiskt.
De flesta hamnar för mycket på det operativa.
Det beror på alla involverades kompetens, det är också vilka frågor som sätts upp.
Men jag tror också att man underskattar formalan, ordförandeskapet, etc.
Stör att skapa den miljön och förberedelser och annat.
Jag tror det var...
Nu gillar jag inte att citera amerikaner för de är inte på min topplista just nu, men Eisenhower tror jag är den som myntade planning is everything, plans are dead.
Alltså hela idén med det är att det är ganska bra att planera, sätta upp agendas, syfte, varför, hur, när, vem.
Det är i business men också i styrelser.
För när man sätter sig där ska man kunna prata om det som faktiskt spelar roll.
Framåtlutat, vad säger vi för trender, vilken strategi ska vi ha, identifiera strategiska insikter, komma över till och finna strategiska val och så småningom också sätta en strategi och arbeta därefter.
Ofta tycker jag att de är relativt dysfunktionella.
Såklart inte de jag arbetar i, alla är perfekt.
Finns det en viss sorts människor som ska sitta i styrelser eller vissa personlighetsdrag som man ska...
Har man de personlighetsdragen då ska man inte vara med i styrelser över huvud taget.
Ja men sitta i styrelse, det är det klassiska misstaget tycker jag och jag sa det innan.
Jag tror att min känsla har varit, i alla dom jag har varit, att det är alldeles för många som har varit så att man sitter i en styrelse.
Man tror att man...
Syftet är...
Ja men nu har jag på något sätt, jag har fått den här frågan.
Egentligen börjar allting där.
Jag har i alla fall personligen, när jag tackade jag det första styrelsearbetet och därefter har det följt.
Jag har alltid varit supernervös.
Jag tänker nej, här måste jag vara påläst, jag måste vara redo, jag läser allting flera gånger.
För jag tänker att det här är jätteviktigt.
Styrelsen är ansvarig på många olika sätt.
På din fråga, vem borde inte sitta?
Alla de som faktiskt tänker att de sitter.
Man ska tänka att man arbetar.
Vill man och känner man att jag har inte tid, då ska man säga nej.
Man ska säkerställa det när man tackar ja.
Vad förväntas utav mig här?
Hur mycket tid ska jag lägga ner och så vidare?
Lejonparten av mina engagemang är ju inte arvruderade.
Om man skulle tänka rent monetärt, utan det värdet jag får där är något annorlunda.
Jag betalar tillbaka eller jag är en del av en resa.
Det är en sån klassisk grej också.
Vissa gör det bra, Filmkorn är faktiskt fantastiskt bra på detta, men vi har gått utbildningar tillsammans också.
Nu har vi en som är utbildare som ordförande, så vi har fuskat lite.
Men det är ju att man faktiskt har en mångfald.
Det gäller inte bara styrelser, det gäller business.
Det är jag också lite nyfiken på att höra dig säga någonting om.
För jag fattar att mångfald är också lite emellanåt lite så.
Det blir lite klyschigt.
Men mångfald i min värld är inte nödvändigtvis någon slags vargadigt ursport.
Mångfald i ålder är väldigt sällan.
Man har en väldigt yng.
Varför har man inga femtonåringar där?
Man får inte för sig ställa den frågan för man tänker att de förstår inte.
Eller att barn, barn är ju kanske en superpower.
Jag använder mina barn som är tolv och femton.
Såklart vet de inte om det alltid.
Men för få, vilken fråga det var.
Vad säger de om detta?
För de är så orörda emellanåt.
Alla vi andra, även du Joel, vi är förstörda på något sätt.
Vi har gått in i de här boxarna och det är så svårt att ta sig ur dem.
Ja, jag köper det.
Samtidigt som man på något sätt kan sin verksamhet bäst så är man fruktansvärt stängd i väldigt många aspekter.
För man testade det någon gång, man gjorde sådär någon gång och det funkade inte och då har man liksom stängt den dörren ganska hårt.
En fråga bara där på arenan.
Du sa att ni har gått den utbildningen tillsammans, ni har en utbildande där som ordförande.
Hur gör man för att ni inte ska bli för kompisaktigt, så att ni inte slutar utvärdera om alla förtjänar sin plats och liknande.
Nu är ni ett gäng liksom.
Ja men inget snack om att ordförande är nyckel där och att man har den kompetensen för att arbeta enligt god styrelse.
Då kommer det efterhand att tvinga att man faktiskt följer...
Grunden är såklart bolagsordningen, sen är det årstemman, där är det makten och sen är det också att man faktiskt, en typisk klassisk exempel, är att man underskattar valberedningen.
Valberedningen är ju de som sonderar terängen på att identifiera vem som ska sitta i styrelsen.
Det är ett systemfel om man inte lägger kraft på det.
Då kan det komma in någon som också sätter kulturen i styrelsen.
Så det har jag lärt mig senaste året att oj, ursäkta, valberedningen är superviktig.
Jag tror att det handlar om att få in rätt personer som är riktigt...
Jag vet inte vilken profil det är.
Jag vet att du intervjuade Jenny.
Hon är ju också här i Helsingborg.
Jenny gillar jag jättemycket.
Hon är fantastisk på många sätt.
Hon är inte så känslig.
Nej, hon bryr sig inte på det sättet.
Förlåt, jag borde inte sätta en label på henne att hon inte bryr sig.
Det är klart att hon bryr sig, men det jag menar är att hon är rakt på.
Hon är inte rädd för att konfrontera extremt osäkert om man får säga så.
Det tror jag är jätteviktigt i den konstellationen.
Att man har dem inte som går runt och skapar dålig stämning hela tiden, men det är livsfarligt att ha gullig stämning.
Då kommer det vara så rätt som det.
I slutet av mötet så dyker det upp en jävfråga som man bara slätar över för alla ska hem.
Så är det den där viktiga frågan om hur tog vi beslut om den investeringen om 1,5 miljoner?
Tål det dagsljus, följer vi det andra.
Det har jag inte berättat för dig, jag är egentligen statsvetare i grunden, så jag har pluggat ut statsvetare.
En sak jag läste var om korruption och varför i Sverige, det finns i Sverige också, varför det är så låg korruption i Sverige och varför vi har byggt ut social tillit etc.
Men korruption är inte bara det vi ser på nyheter om kriminella och så vidare, det finns faktiskt i de här vem som faktorerar vem och vem att testerar det där utlägget och så.
För mig, med min bakgrund i alla fall, så som jag är frustrat så är det det började i det lilla också.
Alltså det finns ju, det behöver man inte hamna i för mycket men så är det ju definitivt, det finns ju inte, det finns ju rätt många underupphandlingar i det offentliga som om de hade granskats ordentligt så är det ju väldigt tydligt att fan den här är ju skriven för att en viss aktör ska vinna den här upphandlingen.
Förlåt, vad heter han?
Han är också duktig på LinkedIn, är det Jens som av?
Är det en slösade jobb som han...
Jajajaja, alltså fantastiskt jobb han har gjort.
Tänk såklart att verkligen sätta ljuset på det där, så mycket peng.
Men Joel, hur är det med, jag har inte kollat på hur jobbar ni då?
Har du någon styrelse eller?
Du har kört, du freebasa.
Men jag tycker att det är väldigt intressant, jag tycker att alla sådana här grejer som är, som i mitt syn är riktiga bolag.
Allting som ingår i den korrekta bolagsstyrningen på något sätt.
Det tycker jag är väldigt spännande, det är bara att jag orkar inte med det typ.
Jag jobbar på Contenter så har jag med mig, vi är tre större ägare, två partners då, Dan Nilsson som du säkert känner till och Karsten Deppert.
Dan skulle nog bara säga exakt lika det.
Jag kan se hur han, hela hans kropp när vi har styrelsemöte, den går i konvulsion.
Jag är likadant.
Han sitter där i tören, han säger inte ett ord, men när han väl säger så är det bara så, de 45 minuter vi har dratt så bara så.
Ett sånt, tänk att det är strikethrough överallt, okej, men han är med, det är inget snack, men jag vet att han gillar inte det där.
Det är inte så att jag älskar det heller.
Min take är ju, jag jobbar i bolag som inte har styrelser och tycker att de har bättre styrelsearbete än vissa som har styrelser.
Är du med vad jag menar?
Ja, jag fattar.
Det kan ju inte vara egentligen ett ännu ett lager.
Jag kan verkligen känna med honom, allting som ska göras för att det ska göras, det kan inte jag göra.
Jag fattar det.
Jag får gärna bara stänga av.
Men nu ska vi prata lite grann om contentor.
Det är liksom ett case som jag är intresserad av.
Du sa lite grann att ni gjorde översättningar, fast inte översättningar.
Kan du inte bara förklara lite grann vad contentor gör, lite vad ni gjorde för fem år sedan, vad som har hänt under de här fem åren, vilken transformation ni är i.
Give us the story och nörda ner i det du vill nörda ner i.
Jag ska göra det.
Men jag vill ändå säga, jag vill börja någonstans i någon slags, alltså utfatta inte mig som, jag är en tänkare i många fall.
Så jag tvekar, jag tvekar, jag tvekar.
Och sen så kanske det verkar som så ovarbeslutsamt, ovarrakt, ovarhandlingsskatt och så vidare.
Men jag är sån, det känns så avklädt, han har ju delat det i så här podd.
Men nu sitter vi här så känns det som, jag vet att du har säkert en och en annan lyssnare, så det här kommer ju komma ut.
Men det är fortfarande så.
Nu är vi på ett bättre ställe, inget snack.
Alltså nu har jag ju också själv tränat jättemycket och så är det påverkat men det har varit fem, sex år av direkt lidande och ångest.
Alltså, om man ser så att de fram tills för något år sedan eller ett och ett halvt år sedan så var det nog fler dagar i veckan där jag bara ville lägga ner, än jag ville fortsätta.
Och då gäller det att contenta.
Och idag är det tvärtom skulle jag säga, så det är positivt.
Vi har aldrig presterat så bra som vi har gjort de senaste trettio månaderna.
Vi har aldrig, jag skulle säga vi, men i många fall så är det säkert jag.
Det bara smal ner.
Chachapiti tycker jag ändå var, när det kom, det var ju som ett iPhone-moment, inget snack.
I vår bransch så var det så här.
Det var lågkonjunktur plus Chachapiti som en gnista.
Vi tappade 75 procent av kunderna, alltså på riktigt nästan överrennat.
Det du har skrivit till mig i de här DMs på LinkedIn, du var snäll där, jag fick det utepå LinkedIn.
De sa inte rakt ut till oss, men de sa varför ska jag betala dig en halv miljon, vilket det kostade då kanske då, för att expandera till en-två marknader.
När kan vi göra detta för 500 kronor?
Det var en sån fråga som bara höll mig vaken så länge.
För på ett sätt kände jag det själv.
Vi kommer att komma tillbaka då kring, för jag vet att du också säkert tänker, varför spelar språk en roll då?
Vad är bra språk eller vad är bra innehåll?
Vad ska jag med det?
Jag vill ändå komma tillbaka att vi satte oss ner.
Jag och Karsten, Dan och vi hade väl några, och det var en vecka som var ganska tuff.
Därför att vi så, vi började blöda ganska radikalt.
Vi tappade, har sommerat så småningom.
Två, fast att vi alltid har varit supersnabba, agila, du vet så, steget före.
Jag kan säga så, jag ska vara helt ärlig.
2020 så satte vi i en nya strategiska planen, vi kallade en Rediscover-contentor.
Och jag har kvar det, de mailen från OpenAI.
Jag tror inte många 2020 visste vad OpenAI var.
Men då var vi med i en playground i deras, de hade GPT One och så var vi med i nånstans private beta slack-kanal.
Och fast att om man tittar efter så var så fast, sen var tidigare de var, men noll chans hade vi det här, chat-GPT.
Det kom, blödde 2,5 miljoner, tappade 75 procent av kunderna.
Stränden direkt så, okej, dags att dö.
Det var bara så, vi satte oss ner och tänkte och funderade.
Å ena sidan så var det nog delvis lite pannvän tror jag.
Jag var lite irriterad för så fort man sa att vi ska avveckla då blev det nästan tvärtom för mig.
Rentlogiskt skulle vi säkert ha avvecklat.
Inget snack därför att det dro ner.
Det var pengar vi hade tjänat in efter, kallade covid-dopningen, därför att den dopade hela e-handeln.
På något sätt är det ännu mer extremt att ni precis har gått igenom en covid-hype när alla e-handlare skulle expandera.
Absolut, och du vet, när jag kom in på kontenter, vet jag inte ifall jag får dela detta men...
Jo, jag skiter i det.
Det är varken dans eller castens fel, men jag kom in, jag sa faktiskt nej tre gånger kring det här vd.
Jag hade varit vd och jobbat i Malmö, och sen så hade jag lovet min fru, ta nu inga vd-jobb och inte i entreprenörsbolag.
Du vet jag har jobbat på hd och Folksam Stora Corp, saker och ting är på plats.
Och så har jag jobbat med de här entreprenörerna.
De har noll koll, de är grymma, de är snabba, smarta, kloka men ingen ordning.
Du säger att du lär, så det känner jag igen dig, misstänker jag.
Ja, nej det är lugnt, vi vet var vi är.
Och så Dan och Klasen övertygade mig, egentligen övertygade mig mer med sin aura.
Jag tyckte, oj det här var smarta men också varma människan.
Vilken combo.
Efter två månader så lärde jag mig efter granskat och så vidare.
Bolaget som hade växt 50% varje år tack vare e-handeln och så vidare såg jättebra ut.
Vi hade kontor i Berlin och i Köpenhamn och blödde som bara den.
Så vi hade förbrukat som du vet kontrollbalanslänkning, vårt egna kapital.
Vi steg in, revisen tog över och då hade jag åtta månader eller vi hade det att fixa detta.
Vi löste det, men mina känslor var ju såhär fast.
Det här var inte vad jag sa.
Jag skulle ju ta det här bolaget, det här var en del.
Så jag sa ut mig och började off-worlda.
En dag satt jag och Dan och sa men är det inte något sätt som kan få dig att stanna då?
Så sa jag, jag nöjer mig med halva bolaget.
Såklart var det på skämt men också lite så.
Jag ville indikera att jag nog inte bara jobba som anställd längre.
Utan jag ville vara med och bygga grejer och också faktiskt ställa en kraft och det jag investerat ville jag ta del.
Det ledde till slut till att jag signade vidare och blev delägare och så resan fortsatte.
Det jag ville komma fram till är att när vi hade löst detta så resterade vi och sen kom covid och under tiden så blev vi approached.
Och jag fick lära mig det här med exit också, att man kan göra massa pengar för att man visar på en massa fräckarkopier och andra kan tycka att man gör bra grejer.
Så under en tid blev vi approached av en hantfull med riktiga bud, letter of intent, och precis innan den här, låt oss kalla den dödsveckan eller iphone moment, då när vi började blöda, då hade vi precis tackat nej till, ja men vi fick faktiskt ett bud på 75 miljoner på bordet av en sajös aktör, bland tre andra, kom ganska långt.
Jag skärmdumpade detta tid till dagen tror jag för någon månad sedan, för vi tittade på vårt motbud, nej vi trodde det värt 100 miljoner.
Alltså fattar du när jag såg detta under den tiden där vi mådde som sämst, när vi tänkte att vi skulle kursa, och tittade på det så tänkte jag, vad är det för fel, det måste ha varit fel i huvudet på oss.
På andra sidan så har vi heller inte varit, vi har inte varit drivna av pengar i sig, pengar för mig är mer ett medel, en frihet att kunna göra det man vill.
Det vi har varit riktigt bra på, jag vet inte vad vi är, vad vi erbjuder, det här blev ett långt svar Joel, men du sa det här, håll upp håll upp.
Det ska vara ett långt svar, kör på, jag älskar det.
Jag vet inte riktigt vad vi gör, jag vet inte vad Aoi faktiskt är.
Det är en teknologi, vi har alltid varit duktiga på nya teknologier.
Jag tror att vi är en massa förändringsagenter på kontenter.
Vi startade egentligen inte som ett översättningsbolag, utan det var handlare som behövde innehåll till sin e-handel.
Så det var ju innan e-handel ens.
Alltså, då folk sa så kommer man att handla online.
Tänk dig det.
Så det var på den tiden.
Och sen så råkade det vara att vi tänkte att man behöver nog översätta.
Det gick, kontenter hette innehållsfabriken.
Hittade jag en sån gammal dropbox-folder.
Sexigt namn.
Ja, eller hur.
Tryckte det in, keyword-stuffing, massa innehåll.
Google gillade det, va?
Och sen var det så typiskt, och Karsten, men Dan som är så sjukt vass person, intelligent, men också väldigt lat, förlåt Dan igen.
Så när det var så att hans kompisar då i e-handelssverige kom, ja men vi behöver också innehåll.
Och sen så bara sa han, vi behöver innehåll till Danmark.
Nu ska vi sälja i Danmark, Norge och Finland.
Så insåg man, ja men det går ju fast en snabbare än att skriva, att låta studenterna skriva texterna på de här språk.
Så det går snabbare att översätta.
Så då blev vi ju så småningom då ett översättningsbolag.
Som kunde SEO, TechSavvy, fattar att inte ta sönder filorna och hela den biten.
Så småningom tog Contentor in, det var innan min tid.
Investerare, ganska grymma investerare faktiskt, gängelinvesterare som Anton Johansson på Grebban, Philip Larsson som varit med på Storytel, Stefan Mahlstein, Warren Campbell och nu också Mikke Victor och Morten Persson, Akke, min egenbror som var här med en liten post som fick mig att signa i början.
Och det här var...
Alltså vi har pivotat, egentligen har vi varit förändringsagentar hela tiden.
Du kan ju på att se det här.
Såklart har vi en historia av att vara proaktiva, vi har jobbat med text, vi håller på med API och egentligen vår mission.
Det handlar om att reducera eller eliminera slöseriet av mänsklig intelligens.
Alla de här mailen fram och tillbaka, det är egentligen det vi har försökt lösa.
Så vad kontenter gör kanske lättar oss.
Alltså vad jag tror att vi är så småningom.
Men vi är förändringsagenter just nu.
Jag hoppas att inga kunder missuppfattar detta.
Därför att vi är nog bäst i Sverige och i Norden på det vi gör.
Det vet jag nu hundra procent.
Därför att jag ser konkurrenter och jag ser helheten i det vi gör.
Det är att vi finansierar experimenterande egentligen.
Så vi levererar de bästa översättningarna tycker jag.
Vi levererar processdesign med vilka flöden man ska ha.
Världsklassprojekt och så vidare.
Men egentligen det vi gör just nu, det är egentligen bara finansierar, vi lönsar man ut, för att fortsätta varje dag experimentera med AI.
Vad ska man göra med AI?
Och vi har under de två tre åren som har varit här nu, utan att veta om det, byggt ett nytt gränssnitt, skapat nya tjänster, förändrat livet för översättarna och lingvisterna.
De gör något helt annat.
Det är AI som översätter.
Men det är vi människor som både faciliterar innan datan ska in i elelementen, vi skapar kontexten, intentionen och målet.
Vi har personer som monitorerar, därför att alla som på riktigt jobbar med detta i stor skala, det är 30 marknader, miljontals ord, alltså massor med texter, de inser att saker och ting kan gå sönder, så då identifierar vi de problemen.
Och framförallt jättemycket tid använder vi våra linguister till numera, jag vet inte vad vi ska kalla dem, men de har fått en ny roll utan att de nästan vet om det.
Framtidssäkrare jobb är att granska, validera och gradera outputen av den här AI-en och sen så återinföra de findings vi gör för att göra modellen lite bättre, lite vassare och så vidare.
Om tre år, vet inte.
Då tror jag att vi är tillbaka på innehållsfabriken, då tror jag att man skapar content, man översätter ingenting.
Man skapar content från scratch på alla språk, men människorna kommer att förmodligen vara viktiga, men på ett annat sätt.
Om det makes sense, jag vet inte ifall det låter vimligt.
Istället för att vara en översättare som sitter och skriver så är ni mer som en, jag vet inte vad man kallar det på sådant språk, men en programvara som man nyttjar för sin e-handel, det är det som jag ska förstå det som.
Ja exakt, min pitch till alla våra kunder men också internt, vad jag själv ser, jag tittar mig själv i spegeln och frågar vad är ni?
Jag säger så, Rabi vad är du och vad är ni?
Vi är en partner och en partner har en helhet.
Helhet i bemärkelsen av att vi kan ställa de rätta frågorna.
Där finns vissa delar som handlar om att vi är e-handels eller retail, och nu har vi faktiskt några kunder som vi inte har approachat, men det är alltså enterprises, några av världens största bolag som har kommit till oss för att leverera i ett visst värde.
Men det är en kritisk vän man kommer för att man egentligen ska reducera risken av att själv välja en eventuell frilansare eller linguist eller så här.
Vi säkerställer att ha den här communityn som vi ändå har investerat 20 år i nu snart.
Alla våra linguister har ju gått igenom tester och de är ju flera hundra.
Nu är de i färgen vad vi hade för några år sen som var 700 till 1000 och det är klart att det är omsättning.
Men alla de, de har genomgått tester.
Vi vet hur de ser ut, vi vet vad de heter.
Det är inte så att vi vet ofta om de går på semester eller annat.
Så det är inte så att de är anställda, direkt så är de projektanställda och det är lite gigarbete.
Men det är den här kritiska vännen.
Sen har vi en stor del i själva plattformen.
Alltså ett space där våra kunder kan göra det själv.
Det de har gjort här nu senaste två tre åren.
Gått in på chatchipitik, kladd etc.
Eller pluggat in via integrationen.
Men man gör det i mycket säkrare ställe och lite bättre.
Alltså inte vaniljsmak utan den som är riktigt anpassad till om det nu skulle vara gymkompanieriet eller samsung eller Dyson eller Edblad de vi jobbar med, sätter tonaliteten och det är något rörligt.
Jag menar det justeras efter hand.
Och i slutändan så klart gör vi fortfarande lite av det gamla också.
För ibland så måste man stanna upp och skapa top-nodge-kvalitet.
Det får inte ens vara ett enda fel.
Jag tror jag kommer tillbaka till, jag vet inte om det var du som ställde den frågan eller om det där hoppar upp i morse och jag lyssnar på någon annan podd.
Jag tror du skrev så, hur vet man då?
Exakt.
Om någonting är bra eller dåligt.
Jag tror att jag som håller på med fotboll tar en referens till det.
En riktigt bra domare märks inte.
En dålig domare kommer att märkas.
Det jag menar så tar bra språk märks knappt.
Men en dåligt språk kommer att potentiellt påverka bounce rate, det kommer att påverka conversion rate.
Det kan kännas som att, på vilket sätt gör du det?
Jo men på 100 så kanske det är en i små, små nyanser.
Det här är inget jag hittar på, det finns forskning på det.
Mer än 60% kommer enbart att handla på sitt eget språk.
Därför att det där dom finner logiken mycket tydligare, dom fattar och känner trovärdigheten.
Dom entusiasmeras av det.
Där finns faktiskt studier som visar på hur många som aldrig skulle besöka en site som inte är på det språket.
Då kan man bara addera det till, jag kan ju översätta, jag använder Aoi.
Det är klart man kan göra det, men jag tror att det är Dan som har gett det.
Om du jämför Paint och Photoshop, finns det någon skillnad?
Det är klart att det kan finnas skillnad.
Jag har ändå så småningom också blivit pragmatisk, så det beror på i allt i mitt case, att jag har lite vilken brand man är, vilken produkt man säljer, vilken fas man är i sin resa och så vidare.
Vilken text det är, hur ska vi behandla?
Så vi behandlar inte all text likadant, utan vi berättar och hjälper kunden när man ska göra det.
Där tror jag att det finns stora stora...
Där vi hade det som tuffast, det var ju när någon bara tryckte på knappen, där kan vi röra själv.
Sen är det så, det har vi nog alla lärt oss, men det finns inga free lunches.
Så det är nästan det här med AI och det här med all respekt och säkta språket.
Det är som att kissa i byxorna, det känns ganska skönt i början, fast sen ingen faktura, men så småningom blir det lite kallare.
Det är knappt man märker, det är risk att man dör så långsamt att man tror att man lever.
Men rätt som det så swishar konkurrenter förbi och så brandawarent som har försvunnit.
Man drankar inte lika högt varken på AI-sök eller SEO och så vidare.
Så klart jag har en partsinlagg här, men jag säger detta därför att jag bryr mig också om Sverige som vad ska man säga, handel och som aktör, därför att jag tror att det finns en profit leakage därute, jag tror att det finns en massa kapitalförstöring.
Vi har ju översatt det när vi skulle in i Danmark till exempel och vi upptäckte ju en, efter du vet, efter en viss tid så upptäckte vi alla de här märkliga, vi säljer till exempel bumperplates som är vanligt inom och det är översatt till kofångerplatter, alltså kofångare på bilen för det är bumper, men mycket sådana udda grejer som dröker upp liksom.
Det jag tycker är spännande för en av anledningarna till att jag tyckte att det var spännande att ha med det är för att, ni gick igenom nedgången men ni har ju också börjat gå upp, eller vad man ska säga, ni är ju liksom på, ni är inte nere i blödningsfasen utan verkar ha kommit in på en liksom återkomstgrej.
Vad är det egentligen när du säljer till en kund nu, jag bara tänker att under några år måste det ha varit en väldigt svår affär att driva på.
Vad är det du säljer in idag, hur ger man argumenten mot en kund idag, att det är det här man ska göra.
För som vi säger, det är så etablerat på något sätt att man kan använda AI i all textproduktion.
Det måste vara samma sak för folk som producerar content, det måste vara helt hopplöst.
Men vad är det du säljer, nu har du gjort lite grann som en pitch, men när du sitter i ett säljmöte, vad ska de ändå betala för det?
Det är rätt, jag ska vara helt transparent där.
Det här är en resa som vi fortfarande är på.
Jag tror det är viktigt att jag ställer mig frågan.
Vi är födda som handlare, men jag tror att en av våra styrkor är att vi har den hatten.
Det är inte så att vi är i våra möten, det är inte en annan som gör det, de sätter kunden i det mötet till och med rent fysiskt som en docka.
Men vi försöker pågå med oss själva.
Om jag och vår är Joel, och jag ska till Danmark, och jag ska till Norge, eller jag vill ta över världen.
Vad är viktigt för mig?
Vad behöver jag tänka?
Då såklart så tänker vi på betallösningar, tekniken, men då tänker vi samma fasen.
Om jag ska dit så behöver jag lokalisera, och då behöver vi förstå den biten.
På ett sätt är det en fråga vi ställer fortfarande, det är ingen färdig lösning.
Men jag tror att vi har nått post, det vi kan kalla post-localisation.
Vi är förbi senigt vad gäller att man tänker att människor skulle översätta.
Det har vi egentligen redan mellan 2018 skulle jag säga och 2023 upptäckte vi att maskinöversättning är ganska bra.
Det går att komma ganska långt med det, inte helt och hållet var för sig.
Det här är en del av det jag brukar förklara för kunder, men okej, i kombination så har vi kunnat se det.
Det visade vi redan värde på.
Innan chatjapti kom så hade vi redan pivotat över till att mer än 50% var faktiskt att mycket av produkttexterna gjorde sig en kombi mellan en maskinöversättning och en mänsklig touch.
Därför att man skulle fatta purpose med att faktiskt göra detta.
Sådant case kan vara som en business-hatten.
Om jag ska in till Finland så säger jag till Joel, låt oss anta pareto-modellen.
Vi tar 80% av din omsättning, vad du tror du skulle komma att sätta.
Så översätter vi bara 20% och lägger bara minsta möjliga kostnader.
Då tror jag att det vi säljer är egentligen förtroende.
Att vi fattar det där.
Vi sätter oss bredvid dig och kan hjälpa dig.
Vi är egentligen inte ett översättningsbolag.
Ett översättningsbolag kommer att försöka göra översättningen perfekt.
Men det är inte det vi säljer.
Vi försöker sälja en motor eller en förmåga att bättre och mer effektivt kommunicera ditt budskap med din mottagare.
I vårt fall så är det till 90% e-handelskunder, brands, retailers som vill få mer trafik till sin sajt, mer konverteringar, sälja, mer växa.
Det vi har lärt oss nu med AI, det har blivit fantastiskt mycket bättre.
Alltså det är superstarkt, det är inget snack.
Men då innebär det också att jävulen eller till och med framgången sitter i detaljerna.
Så contentor har ju kommit att bli, förutom det här jag sa med partnerskap, tänk dig en robotdamsugare.
Vi använder AI som robotdamsugare.
För det första måste man lyfta in den, ge den batterier, in med den i rummet.
Robotdamsugaren kommer missa kanterna.
Där lägger vi in den mänskliga valideringen, eller till och med den sista touchen.
Vi lägger superkrut på att faktiskt lokalisera.
Vad var det för term du nämnde innan när ni skulle till Danmark?
Du sa att det var någon produkt för bogg.
Det vi gör, och det är en klassisk misstag, innan vi sätter igång och börjar skjuta in mot de olika elelemsen, för vi har förmåga att kolla om det är klart, best här eller Google Translate.
Där är det också en sådan, det är jättesvårt för kunden själv.
Oftast väljer man bara DPL eller något så bara.
Men det vore det funka på allt, så är det inte.
Då börjar vi.
Vi fattar det här.
När LePu sa det, eller det var kanske Robinson, du måste veta vart du ska innan du börjar gå, för det riskar att du går åt fel håll annars.
Vi lägger ganska mycket tid, det kostar väldigt lite i förhållande termerna.
Så vi sätter nyckelorden och så lokaliserar vi dem tillsammans med våra bästa linguister.
Så ett första jobb blir, det är inte många timmar, och det är inte många kronor.
Och det har vi fått jättebra feedback på.
Alltså kunderna älskar det när vi satsar, men låt oss börja med det, vi ska sätta det.
Och i den bästa av världar så gör man inte bara lokalisera termerna, utan man faktiskt utmanar på ett mer sofistikerat sätt.
Så tittar man och är vad är det där för sökgård, vilka sökvolymer är det?
I Finland, Ungern, Polen, Kina.
Och sen så låter vi linguisten och SEO-experten samspela.
Linguisten kanske föreslår två tre termer som är rimliga om den här hanteln, eller om det är bänkpress, vad säger man i de länderna?
Och sen så sätter man också sökvolymerna och boom!
Så har man kanske tusen termer som vi sen har hittat en metod för, alltså jobba med context engineering.
Du vet att vi promptar inte bara i chatfönstret såklart, utan vi har ju system prompt, user prompt, vi har till och med splittat promterna för att ha en general prompt och sen så är det här olika språkpromter.
Och då är det ju att tvinga Ayn, som fortfarande hallucinerar och missar, och sen så småningom också, om den inte har rätt kontext, så kommer den att översätta vissa termer på ett annat sätt.
Då har vi hackat systemet lite genom att göra på det här sättet.
Så när Ayn vill göra på ett visst sätt, så säger jag att du ska alltid översätta såhär.
Och vi har do not translate list och så vidare.
Nu kommer mina kollegor att bli sura kanske med den här robotdamsugan va?
Eller nej nej, vi är inte robotdamsugare.
Robotdamsugan är ju den Ayn vi använder.
BOOM!
Det kan ju vem som helst göra kanske, även om vår robotdamsugare är lite vassare som du precis har hört.
Och så är det ju de där kanterna.
Tänk dig då när alla har köpt robotdamsugare, alla är handlare.
Hur konkurrerar du då?
Och det är det man egentligen tar armklok med contentor i, det är att vi kommer vara den som som som sagt hjälper våra kunder.
Förra veckan så fick jag, och det här hittar jag inte på faktiskt, och det här fattar jag sen att vi inte bara, vi håller inte på med översättningar i innehåll, men en kund sa, varför vi valde det?
För nu har jag berättat hjälp av vår CMO, att nu ska vi få också lite sån här recensioner, nu är vi vassa faktiskt, nu måste vi berätta om detta.
Och då sa jag, jag vill veta varför ni har valt contentor, varför väljer ni contentor framför det här, världens största översättningsbolag?
Det är faktiskt för att ni hjälper oss att implementera AI i ett rimligt use case.
Och då fattar jag också, tack vare oss, så hjälper vi de här kunderna att göra AI användbart.
På LinkedIn och överallt så ser du i jäkla hype alla de här bilderna och alla som man gör.
Vad är det för värde egentligen med AI?
Att hitta de här use casen där AI på riktigt inte bara ersätter och sparar tid, utan får ett budskap att evolvera.
Jag fattar då att den här kunden säger att det är jättesvårt.
De sitter i styrelserum och vd och tänker hur ska vi bli mer framtidssäkra?
Hur ska vi få in en kultur där vi använder AI?
Vad är vår process och allt?
Då förstår jag, vi ger ganska hands-on delar där AI finns i rummet.
Vi pratar i terminologin, vi utsätter dem för att testa de sakerna.
Så det har kommit förlåtande om det blir en pitch, men jag inser att vi är sjukt starka i den benäkelsen.
Översättningshållet är bara typ så, det är en bonusgrej.
Men det riktiga värdet är att ett bolag som då i detta fallet, gratis så kommer de att få möjligheten att helt plötsligt ha förflyttat sin organisation.
Alla de som jobbar nära oss som är oftast fem till tio, tjugo olika intressenter hos Bolagen, de utsätts ju för ett språk eller för gränssnitt eller för annat där AI faktiskt är användbart.
Det är inte knepigt att gå igenom den lite förändringen om jag hårdrar det stenorda, jag fattar att det inte är exakt så.
Men när man kanske en gång i tiden exporterade text, översatte det och skickade in det igen, till att nu så kräver nästan kunden att man ska vara med i någon sorts affärsutveckling av hur ska vi tänka på den här marknaden, hur ska vi göra det här, hur ska vi hitta våra frågor, hur ska vi synas i AI-sök, hur ska vi kunna optimera för agentsök i framtiden.
Det är en helt annan roll.
Dels hur personalen har fått hantera det och dels hur, för jag gissar att ni också måste ha gått över till en annan faktureringsmodell än vad man hade tidigare när man liksom tog 60 öre per ord eller vad man kan ha gjort och nu så ska man plötsligt.
Hur har den processen gått till?
Jag tror att den världen, det har jag inte ens nämnt om, men jag tror AI är faktiskt en affärsmodell förändring, snarare än någonting annat.
Alltså den förändra saker och ting jag var på SAS i Estanu med i Malmö, Thomas Sjöberg och Daniel Narkowski.
Fantastisk event förresten, det var riktigt bra.
Och då var det jättemånga olika SAS-bolag som delade just det här, vad är AI och hela den biten?
Det är jättemycket agenter just nu och superpromter och så.
Min take nu som har andats det här nu, på riktigt alltså så länge, är att det här är något annat.
Det är något som disruptar egentligen affärsmodellen, den utmanar hur vi tar betalt.
Så du har helt rätt, jag har märkt det på fakturorna.
Så det är klart att vi har, alltså vår omsättning har ju gått ner.
Men helt ärligt så är vi mycket mer lönsamma.
Så vi skapar värde för alla intressenter.
Våra kunder är glada och därför att de, innan fakturerar vi behöver inte säga de kunderna, 200 000 per månad och sen så är det 20 000 nu.
Men för mig är det fine.
Det är klart att jag hade gillat att ha en högre omsättning där.
Men återigen om vi ska gå tillbaka till det så tror jag att det handlar om värdeskapande.
Så är det så att det minskar det jobbiga autonoma och vi också procentuellt tjänar mer.
Så handlar det ju bara med om att jag ska få ännu fler att förstå den här modellen.
Så har vi lyckats med detta.
Men ja, jag fattar vad du tänker Joel.
Det är inget snack, den ändrade vår affärsmodell.
Så vi har gått om det gamla som jag alltid också tyckte.
När jag kom in, jag kunde ingenting om språkbranschen.
Det första jag såg, det som var i industrin, det var pris per ord.
Så för mig var det som då egentligen när jag fattade vårt uppdrag, så jag sa, it doesn't make sense.
Så vadå, jag jobbar på tidning, då var det så att man skulle vara konkis, man skulle säga mer med färre ord, so it doesn't make sense.
Men det var så industrin fungerade.
Jag insåg ganska snabbt att contenten egentligen var annorlunda, men vi var en del av en annan.
Att de flesta hade haft den, började som språkbolag och sålde till vad ska man säga, business.
Medan vi började som handlare och så råkade vi sälja språk.
Och då är det så att förståelsen kring att egentligen komma närmare värde, det här kommer att vara en cliffhanger.
Men jag har en vision, där jag så småningom kommer att få dig som kund Joel.
Och det handlar då om att vi kommer ha en plattform där vi kommer att bevisa.
Du kommer inte att betala en krona, utan vi tar en andel på effekten som jag har visat i realtid.
Så att min dröm i affärsmodellen så småningom, och som jag tror Arjen skulle kunna supporta också, att driva vidare att vi tänker om, det är att vi tar betalt på effekt.
Jag vet att jättemånga tänker att det är ett drömscenario, men att man faktiskt inte skulle bry sig om ord etc.
Vi har redan gjort en pivot, så vi gick från det gamla projektbaserade, hur många ord, hur många texter och så vidare.
Den är inte helt död såklart, så någon slags volymaspekt finns med.
Men vi gick över till en SaaS-modell.
Alltså idag har vi något som vi kallar Content-as-a-Service.
Jag har faktiskt skrivit ner Content-as-a-System, och vi fortsätter evolverera här då, men jag är inte riktigt klar där.
Content-as-a-Service innebär att den föddes ur att A-in förändrade hela det här med per ord, därför att det i stort sett översättningarna går nära 0 kronor, så då är det inte relevant längre.
Vad är värdet vi levererar?
Vi paketerar att göra det enklare, mitt i kundens lågkonjunktur.
Då jag fattade och vi fattade att då är det jätteviktigt att veta hur mycket man behöver betala varje månad.
Så det är viktigt från sådant som Joel att faktiskt få förståelse för hur mycket bör jag estimera att vi behöver investera hos er och vad är det vi får för pengarna.
Vad säger du, vill han skatte-nissen eller vem du var?
Vad fasen får jag för pengarna?
Det var så, verkligen så det ringde i huvudet.
Så vi paketerade om och helt förändrat den plan.
Vi är inte unika på något sätt, det är jättemånga andra som har säkert tänkt i den här generationsvarianten.
Men vi sa så, det värdet vi har, det har vi har i väggarna här, alldeles, det är värt någonting.
Du behöver kommitta, men det är 20 gånger billigare än vad det var förr i världen.
Men det är inte det viktiga, utan det är just värdet.
Oin disruptade ganska ordentligt, contenta gick och har gått från den här med dockiga reaktiva.
Mycket sprunget utav språkindustrin, men också för att e-handlar ursäkta språket.
Vad så jäkla scenar på.
De insåg inte, det var alltid så.
Jag visste att det var språk också.
Vi ska ju lansera nästa vecka.
Fast att det var en av de viktiga.
Det var så att vi behöver detta nästa vecka.
Det var en sån grej, inte så jäkla hett med översättningar.
Den var långt ner och väldigt reaktiv.
Det påverkade så klart sådana som oss.
Men O-In har öppnat upp.
O-In har varit en kniv på vår strupe.
Det har varit en lyx.
Jag återigen, det är inget val när man blir så utsatt som vi gör.
Du måste konfrontera alla demoner och alla problem och hitta lösningar.
Det är en lyx tycker jag.
Då går du med på instinkt, du testar, du failar, du börjar om.
Så affärsmodellen nu är mycket mer den här prenumerationen.
Drömscenariot är ju, förhoppningen är så småningom, att du ska kunna logga in på vår plattform.
Om det nu är online fortfarande, eller om det är på ett annat sätt, det vet jag inte.
Om det är olika för agenterna och för människorna, det vet jag inte.
Men, säg att det är på vår ru då man går in.
Där ska man kunna signa ut, kosta ingenting, använda oss.
Vill du ha alla de här grodbitarna så så har jag en andel på din lönsamhet eller din omsättning på den nya marknaden.
Vi kopplar ihop våra system, om det är Google Analytics eller Google Search Console, om du är med på det.
Såklart kan du använda den gamla modellen också om du hellre vill betala upfront, men jag tror att om vi lyckas med den biten, alltså utveckla och sälja tekniken och distributionen där, så är jag i alla fall mycket mer taggad på något sådant.
Jag tror på vårt tjänst och vårt produkt.
Så det är no brainer.
Jag tror på att om vi får lägga vår hand på saker och ting, och det har vi flera bevis på, då kommer vi att dubbla din omsättning om tre år.
Är det värt någonting?
Ja, vad är det värt då?
Och då vill jag ha lite, kanske mer än de här 20 000 i månaden.
Då vill jag på riktigt också få dela på kaken.
Ja, fan det ska bli jävla spännande.
Vi får nästan göra en, jag tror jag har hunnit med tre av de frågorna jag ville innan.
Förlåt, förlåt.
Jag har bara haft mycket.
Det är jävligt spännande.
Jag tror att man behöver ha lite den.
Det är ju tydligt att du är passionerad över det du snackar om, men man behöver nog ha det om man ska driva igenom fem som är år, annars skiter det sig nog.
Men det ska bli spännande att se vart ni är någonstans om fem år när det har liksom fortsatt.
Det ska bli jävligt kul.
En disclaimer är att jag tror faktiskt att vi fortsatt är där.
Vi kan dö, men vi kan också flyga.
Men vi kommer inte dö på grund av att vi är dåliga som team och så vidare.
Vi dör, vi beror på att det är inget.
Vi har gjort allt och lite till.
Jag tycker att det här teamet som jag har, Parol, Jonas, Tanja, Caroline, bland annat, Johan, Anders, det är kanske det bästa teamet.
Vi är de här nyckelpersonerna som vi någonsin har haft.
Vi labbar extremt mycket.
Lyckas vi inte beror det i alla fall inte på att vi inte har försökt.
På något sätt, vi har också haft några år i lågkonjunkturen.
Vi är väldigt bundna som sällarköpsvaror till bostadsmarknaden, men det är många konkurrenter som har försvunnit.
Det finns en fördel i det.
Det blir lättare sen.
Hur går det för er just nu?
Vi taktar på oss.
Vi är ett ganska tråkigt, jag säger alltid det, jag vill ha det tråkigaste bolaget i världen.
Jag vill växa samma hela tiden.
Jag vill göra det vi gör och så vill vi göra lite mer.
Jag ska hålla på så här i 25 år.
Det är liksom ingen...
Det går ungefär som förra året, fast lite bättre.
Nu har vi kört på ett tag.
Stort tack för att du var med på podden, det var härligt att få höra.
Stort lycka till de närmsta två åren här.
Tack så mycket Joel, du gör ett fantastiskt bra jobb också tycker jag.
Det är jätteruligt.
Vi brukar prata om dig och dina LinkedIn-inlägg.
Jag tycker det är befriande och jag uppskattar det.
Du har lovat mig, det var ju jag som hörde av mig till dig, om ett samtal, eller hur?
Så jag kommer att följa upp.
Jag vet inte hur det kommer att se ut, om det är en podd eller sms-konversation.
Det får vi ta, men det blir någonting.
Jag har lyckats sneaka in det här i alla fall.
Tack så mycket.
Bra jobbat, tack själv.
Ha det fin.
Det finns inga free lunches, så det är nästan det här med A och I, och det här med all respekt och säkta språket.
Det är som att kissa i byxorna, det känns ganska skönt i början, men fastän ingen faktura så småningom blir det lite kallare.